firestorm around president Trump's
meeting with Vladimir Putin today the
president moved to clarify his comments
that cast doubt on the Russian meddling
in the 2016 election and the president's
support of US intelligence services we
have never been in a worse relationship
with Russia than we are as of a few days
ago and I think that's gotten
substantially better and I think it has
the possibility of getting much better
I accept our intelligence community's
conclusion that Russia's meddling in the
2016 election for the place could be
other people also a lot of people out
there it should have been obvious I
thought it would be obvious but I would
like to clarify just in case it wasn't
and a key sentence in my remarks I said
the word would instead of wooden the
sentence should have been I don't see
any reason why I wouldn't well why
wouldn't be Russian President Obama
along with Brennan and flapper the whole
group that you see on television now
probably getting paid a lot of money by
the network's they knew about Russia's
attempt to interfere in the election in
September and they totally buried it
bingo that last point of course is lost
in much of the media's frothing
hysterical coverage of the controversy
these past two days I've never seen
anything like it but can president from
successfully quell the rage from his
critics some on the right a lot of those
neoconservative never Trump errs and on
the left
joining us now with reaction Matthew or
John ski is a Russia expert director of
the Wilson centers Kenan Institute Don
Braemar a former Intel officer along
with dr. walid Ferris a Fox News foreign
affairs analyst great to have you all on
done I have never witnessed a meltdown
purposeful meltdown on the left and some
on the right after this after this
summit in Helsinki the president comes
out to clarify his remarks today and it
wasn't good enough wasn't good enough
for the media wasn't good enough for
Democrats and as well get to in a few
moments in my angle wasn't good enough
for President Obama although he spoke
before the
clarification your reaction well is it
ever gonna be good enough I mean as the
president said he could part the Red Sea
and it would never be good enough you
know it was a gaffe he messed up who
hasn't made a gaffe on the global stage
I mean President Bush he got sick on in
Tokyo if we forget President Obama he
bowed before the Saudi King so it was a
misspelled JFK Khrushchev as our friend
Craig surely pointed out last night well
lead the Prez the ADEA that the
President of the United States is like
working as a secret mole for Russia on
the world stage in Helsinki and it's
really trying to conspire with Putin to
undermine American interests as he's
hitting the Nordstrom to pipeline as he
kicked out 60 diplomats as he continues
sanctions as he sent lethal weapons to
the Ukraine his actions against Russia
have been tougher than Obama's across
the board and yet all of this is lost on
the Trump hating media and also of
course the Democrats I've never seen
anything like this honestly Laura the
problem is that we have a president who
needs to handle his mission any
president of international security
that's why the summit was supposed to
address
Ukraine the Baltics Syria you know many
issues in Africa in addition to the
nuclear matter which is extremely
important and on the other hand we have
our American politics being displayed in
Helsinki that shouldn't have been the
case the debate about our US politics
should have been in Washington not
addressed there but my concern now is
that many of the countries with whom we
are going to be partnering or containing
are looking at us as undecided if they
cannot decide with Russia and with other
powers as to how to solve these crises
we're gonna lose matthew neer reaction
yeah my sense is that the Russians from
the very beginning you know obviously
they've mucked around in American
politics but their goal here was
primarily to weaken the United States
and when you look at a president who
faces almost certain opposition from
Congress on anything he tries to do in
his view to advance the American
national interest visa vie Russia he's
not going to be able to get it done in
Washington cuz he's going to be blocked
by Congress that's mission accomplished
for the Russians if their goal was to
tie the hands of the President of the
United States now I think this is gonna
back
on russia because in the long term the
united states is the leading world power
and to get the status and recognition
that they need they need to be able to
cut deals with the united states so they
have in effect hamstrung yes the
president but also their own ability to
cut the deals that they need to cut
whether it's on as what we have their
briefs as Ukraine Syria or nuclear
that's a good point I want to share with
all of you this series of hysterical
reactions on the part of the usual
suspects claiming that now we're at a
quote national security crisis because
of what happened in Helsinki let's watch
the fact that the president in this very
weak performance cow-house to Putin and
accepts his version of the facts I
frankly think that's a national security
risk we now have a real national
security emergency in this country this
is a national security crisis and the
president of the United States flew all
the way to Finland met with Vladimir
Putin and basically capitulated what
substantive issued on did the president
capitulate on we stopping sanctions no
longer arming the Ukrainians are we
doing any other other things but
bringing back diplomats that we've
expelled what what did he do no and not
one thing did Putin walk away with he
walked away with a few good minutes of
press that he can go home and build his
propaganda machine you're absolutely
right those sixty diplomats they're
still gone that Washington consulate
still closed we've increased lethality
with our second brigade in Germany we've
put 30 millimeter weapons right on the
front lines to go against his machines
so what did he get he got a few good
minutes on press well II look I think
that the national security stress that
we are going to be facing are really
what's happening now in Syria the
Iranians are taking the borders all the
way to Israel Iraq tonight is falling
apart with all these demonstrations Iran
is moving at they talked about that the
president said they addressed the issue
of Iran behind the distortion Laura
let's the present the two presidents all
other leaders address the national
security or the international security
issues and then at a whole we have our
doesn't care what lead you're acting
like this I'm sorry but the left does
not frankly care about that it's that
it's it's get Trump
kick them out of office impeach them
whatever you can do that's what they're
focused on so you're making this really
good cerebral argument about geopolitics
what's going on what you're hearing from
these senators is outrageously
irresponsible there are serious issues
at hand and to claim that the president
is the poodle of Putin because because
if as you verbal missteps as if Obama
didn't make missteps how about is
disappearing red line which we're gonna
get to in a moment that was a
substantive misstep Matthew your
reaction to that it's a national
security crisis that we spoke with
Vladimir Putin after Obama spent eight
years trying to do a reset that never
happened no I I think that the starting
point for this debate is really partisan
politics in the United States and the
genius of Russia's meddling whatever it
was exactly that they did they targeted
our weakest point they knew that this is
stirring up a hornet's nest and it puts
the United States in a position where
instead of driving hard bargains on for
example Syria we've got to get Iran out
of southern Syria Russia is very
interested in seeing Assad regain
control
so if Russia just gets apart it wants we
don't get Iran out of southern Syria
we can't advance the security of the
State of Israel in that region then we
lose and again a president who's got his
hands tied on foreign policy who's got
the hill out to get him is gonna have a
very hard time doing that that's a win
in Russia and by the way despite the
president's verbal snafus missteps the
last 24 hours
have seen these dangerous hysterics over
Russia and astounding historical litter
illiteracy at the same time here's just
a sample The Washington Post blared it's
not wrong to compare Trump's America to
the Holocaust here's why how about this
from Politico Putin's attacked on the
u.s. is our Pearl Harbor and then this
gem last night on MSNBC I would say that
his performance today will live in
infamy as much as the Pearl Harbor
attack or Kristallnacht I mean I don't
even have words I keep saying I don't
have words for this Walid crystal knock
or Pearl Harbor 2,900 Americans died at
Pearl
I think I'm sure any Jewish Americans
would have a have something to say about
Kristallnacht
unfortunately when our domestic politics
are that deeply divided what we are
going to have is a much more dangerous
situation this whole file will end in
few months let's say a year but the
results that we see on the ground
internationally we're going to pay for
that if we don't if I not united against
them done well I look I completely agree
finally we've got to move forward from
this you know as long as we stay divided
that all of our adversaries continue to
win but our the in is the Intel
community demoralized crippled upset
about what Donald Trump did in Helsinki
that's hard to say generalize but that's
what you hear from the left oh he's he's
destroying the morale of the Intel
community as if the Intel community is
perfect we screwed up a lot along the
way for decades we've gotten things
wrong cataclysmic Intel failures but a
lot of successes too I mean that's just
the way life is well we the Cold War
would have never decreased had it not
been for the Intel committee and the
professionals we have sure mistakes are
gonna be made and you're gonna have
people who are better at their job than
others in the Intel committee just as
you do in any profession but I think at
the end of the day most Intel pretzels
they move forward they know their job
they do it right whatever happened in
the world's favorite politics they put
that behind them because they've seen
this before
yeah and it says it's the heads of the
Intel agencies and the things that
people like Brennan are saying
traitorous treasonous when a when a
former CIA chief is going to that level
of rhetoric about the current President
of the United States
no wonder president Trump thinks that
when he was running for president this
guy was was what was working to try to
prevent him from being president I mean
we're going to we're going to treason
that honestly that and my my old friend
George Will had a very unfortunate
column today it was called I think a
wreck we have the full screen of it
think we do it's called the sad
embarrassing wreck of a man it's always
personal to America's child President
had a play date with a KGB alumnus who
surely enjoyed providing day care blah
blah blah again very very personal
Matthew close it out for us listen Laura
if I had the president's ear what I
would tell him to do right now
he's got some really smart people
advising him have his senior national
security officials work out a good deal
with Russia whether it's on getting Iran
out of Syria whether it's a renewal of
nuclear arms control which we have to do
Russia is the world's other major
nuclear power we have to do doing that
everybody's call-call everybody's bluff
by bringing that deal back to Washington
and saying to the Senate look you're
gonna ratify it or not and then it's on
everyone's record did they support it
did they not support a good deal for the
United States of America and they can't
play politics with it or that's an but
they pay the price and that's a
substantive determination that we could
everyone can put their cards on the
table and I think they are working on
that strategic maturity that we need
exactly excellent panel guys thanks so
much